throughout the years the gaming
community has coined new terms and
changed the thinking behind other terms
as well
for example the word easter egg is well
an egg usually painted during the easter
holiday but in the gaming community
these are hidden features made by
developers that could be references to
other pieces of media
there are a plethora of terms like this
but i feel none are as legendary as
the trick shot for years people have
been creating new trick shots and
evolving old ones trick shots have
started since gaming has started but
most have probably heard of trick
shotting since the early days of call of
duty i mean an entire clan was made out
of this one idea
jumping off of maps constantly failing
or getting shot at just for that one
time your crosshairs line up perfectly
it's not just call of duty pretty much
any game has trick shots it just all
depends on the game but
one thing that every trickshot has in
common is that it's well
uncommon it's not the norm it would be
much easier to just shoot the weapon how
it was intended rather than spending
those hours failing for
one success like i said it's not the
norm but one game
makes it the norm
rise and shine birthday bear
bullet storm is a game with trick
shotting in mind it's the main core
mechanic of this game
here's just a quick example of the
detail put into them killing someone by
shooting them in the head is a headshot
well what about a different gun
say the penetrator that would be called
a root canal what about the neck
that'd be a gag reflex the butt is
called rear entry and even the nuts are
nutcracker there are 131 different trick
shots the player can do that are
recognized by the game
that means the minimum is 131. who's to
say something i do in game isn't a trick
shot just because the game doesn't have
a name for it
it makes you feel that same level of
satisfaction of finally hitting that
shot you've been trying to land
bloodstorm gives the player the freedom
to do any trick they want by building
the map design around this mechanic
throughout certain areas you'll find
explosive balls
cactuses or electrical wires that
instantly tell the player they should
utilize this
not every area of combat has an
environmental hazard however as tonight
everything seem repetitive and actually
give the player a chance to be more
creative if every place had cactuses i
would obviously just end up using that
all game but by not always adding
everything it makes the combat more
unique and enjoyable
everything can be used to your advantage
in some way even when there is nothing
around for example we have an empty room
with no hazards
what are we going to do well let's
bounce them off the ceiling
[Applause]
there is very rarely going to be a
situation where you can't do anything
during combat but just shoot
and of course like we previously
discussed shooting is perfectly okay
since there's skill shots for just
shooting like tripping someone while
they sprint or burning an entire group
with one shot
at any point you can simply click the
back button and look through the
challenges you've completed and have not
completed
it's good to freshen up on some of those
bread and butter skill shots that are
going to be useful during the echoes
which we'll discuss a little bit later
even in the campaign it's nice to
freshen up on these i feel it takes away
from that moment-to-moment action of the
combat if you're constantly pressing the
back button to look up a skill you
forgot how to do
it feels more fluid when everything is
second nature in your head and you can
do them without thinking
the game gives you ample time to
complete these skill shots since you
receive a notification and drop kits
when new challenges have been unlocked
letting you know that something with
that skill shot is coming up
for example at one drop kit it talked
about this new skill shot involving some
parasites then five seconds later there
they are in the middle of the street
on top of that the weapons and upgrades
are unlocked at a steady pace as
well not every weapon is unlocked right
away and even when it's available its
charge shot version might not be
accessible for a while
it helps not make the player overwhelmed
with so many options assuming of course
you're going for those new challenges
and not just sticking to the ones you
know
the reason this is beneficial is that
every time you do complete a new
challenge you get more points than
normal
so doing a red challenge will start out
at 500 then go to 100 points afterwards
the game also realizes how infuriating
it can be to try to get one weapon
finished in the limited time that you
receive it
in my case i was having a bit of
difficulty getting some of the
challenges done for the bouncer since i
didn't really enjoy the weapon and
didn't feel like wasting skill points to
buy ammo for it
you get the bouncer around act 4 and
there are 7 acts in the game so you're
already halfway through the game
so you have less time to complete the
weapon but when you beat the story you
unlock
overkill mode you restart the campaign
with all weapons unlocked and any weapon
you fully finish the challenges for
get unlimited ammo so i now have tons
more situations i know i can get the
challenges in this happened to me
numerous times
challenges i know i could get done if i
just went back to those old areas with
the weapons but i couldn't because the
weapon wasn't accessible yet at this
point it also adds more play time to the
campaign since it's fun to see what new
things you can do by having all the
weapons right at the start this was a
nice addition to the game seeing as the
campaign was honestly quite short only
taking around 6 hours on my first
playthrough on normal difficulty
speaking of which i've already summed up
a good portion of the gameplay so let's
talk about that campaign for a bit
bulletstorm is quite unique in its
dialogue it's something i can imagine in
edgy teen in 2010 making
dick jokes the occasional racial slur
and other phrases related to that sort
of thing there's an option to turn this
stuff off but i personally think that's
what sets this apart from other fps
games it's a somewhat serious story but
it's mostly to laugh at and have fun
with for a brief description of the
opening minutes we are grayson hunt the
leader of a team called dead echo
grayson and the team works under a
general serrano who asked them to carry
out assassination missions
dead echo eliminated numerous mass
murderers gun runners and slave traders
or
so they thought one member of the team
ishii looked through their recent
contract's email to discover that they
were actually just a reporter he was
going to expose
everything that dead echo and serrano
was doing the team had been tricked this
entire time and they were just killing
people serrano didn't like so they went
rogue and escaped the planet
before they could do that however they
were overrun briefly by some guards and
were distracted by a young girl who we
can assume is the reporter's daughter
we can see what the gang has been up to
all these years outside the planet's
atmosphere which seems to just be
drinking and killing bounty hunters
the sooner you answer our questions the
better the odds we don't miss a bottle
and evaporate your face
some viewers watching that clip may have
recognized grayson's voice actor that
being steve bloom who also voiced
dempsey and call of duty zombies as well
as spike in cowboy bebop
i think he's a perfect fit for grayson
and it was also interesting to see him
voice a more vulgar-speaking character
grayson has been dead set on killing
serrano but his
other members aren't too keen on it they
just seem to just want to live and deal
with the occasional bounty hunter
grayson commands them to get the weapons
ready as general serrano's prize ship
the ulysses has arrived it rips right
through the ship and grayson decides to
drive it right into the side of the ship
in hopes of at least taking serrano with
him by some miracle they both live and
they're now stranded on this unknown
planet with crazy inhabitants
sadly however it's not too long after
their arrival that we see grayson's
entire team get killed
except ishii who is now kind of part
robot the main objective for the rest of
the game is getting a ship off the
planet
and possibly killing serrano the only
reason i say possibly is because ishii
is now this very angry pissed off robot
who sometimes can't control the ai in
his head and he's also really annoyed at
grayson for causing all the mess and
getting the squad killed over some petty
revenge so he thinks getting a ship out
of here is more important than anything
grayson has in mind before grayson's
squad was wiped we get to see one of
serrano's guards in action we also get
to pick up his leash and the ability to
open drop kits the drop kits are where
we get to spend our skill points and
there's actually a lore friendly reason
for the skill points serrano only wants
the best in his army so by
performing certain feats of skills the
person will get the ability to resupply
their ammo
those who don't perform high enough
don't get to resupply and usually end up
dying it's not a complex reason but it's
a good attempt at at least trying to
explain what these are as we continue
through the area with ishi we hear a
radio call from one of the final echoes
soldiers both grayson and nishi assume
that if they can make it to her they can
make it off the planet with her help
after killing hundreds of enemies
shooting down helicopters dodging a
giant grind wheel and killing some
creatures babies we make it to the echo
soldier
oh listen lady please we've been stuck
here forever
help us get an evac off world yeah go
[ __ ] yourself
you [ __ ] piles give chase i will kill
your dicks
what what does that even mean you're
gonna kill my dick
i'll kill your dick how about that huh
[ __ ] so we have to chase her once again
we go through even more areas one of
which being a godzilla city lookalike
and we get chased by
this giant thing and have to make a run
for it until we realize it's just a dude
controlling it
hope you had fun
now we get to control the mechaton and
easily cruise to the upcoming area
it's in the next area though that we get
to run into the second faction called
the creeps i probably should have
mentioned this before but the first
group you face
are called the skulls the skulls are
quite easy to defeat besides the guys
with flare guns that can dodge the leash
the creeps however dodge kicks so the
only way to trip them is to slide into
them
after a few minutes of fighting them we
finally get to make it to the echo
soldier named trishka
i forgot that games around this time in
2010 2012 always had those weirdly
placed ash shots kind of like mass
effect
2 with miranda 11 year old me would have
loved this sort of thing but now i just
kind of think it's forced i don't really
care too much about it though if it's
there it's there if it's not it's not
it's not really that big of a deal at
the end of the day trishka is now going
to escort us to general serrano's escape
pod which is on top of a large tower in
between is more combat and a third
faction called the burnouts which are
severely mutated creatures that can only
be killed by destroying the glowing
parts on their body we also get to see
more of the planet's plant life in the
form of venus fly traps and
whatever this is we do get a brief
cutscene with the group where ishii goes
on ahead and splits off from trishka but
it's also here that we discover a very
interesting twist that trishka's father
was the reporter we killed in the intro
she was the little girl we saw in the
beginning too
the reason she joined the military was
to kill the people who killed her father
so we maybe don't want to tell her the
full truth just yet shortly after this
we do hear a bit of rumbling out on the
streets remember when i said we were
destroying some creatures eggs a little
bit ago
it's back
we go into a huge boss fight and end up
killing it and then we meet serrano it's
a little intense at this point as both
grayson and serrano want to kill one
another but serrano attempts to lessen
the tension by pushing trishka off the
building
this is arguably one of the better parts
of the game because it's now ishii
serrano and grayson fighting together
and they're constantly bickering at one
another and you could feel the hatred
between them the whole reason these
three are together is because serrano's
dna bomb is going to blow up the planet
in two hours but any evacuation pilots
are not going to be available for three
hours so they have to deactivate the
bomb before they die
at some point serrano gets split off
from the group and ishii and grayson
have a heart to heart for a bit he
explains that no matter what the ai says
or does he joined grayson on his
adventures from his own free will
it's not grayson's fault for everybody
dying all of them could have simply just
left the group and stayed on their own
but all of them chose to stay together
it helps grayson a lot since he blames
himself for everything that has occurred
so far
grayson ishii and serrano make it to the
bomb where two very obvious things occur
serrano betrays them and trishka isn't
actually dead honestly i knew the moment
she fell off the building that she was
going to be okay
you don't just kill off a character like
that with no sympathy or emotion in it
at all
i felt that both of these were so
obvious that i wasn't really blown away
by it
i'm assuming the developers tried to
make the plot twist work but for me it
just kind of fell flat we then have to
chase serrano through the ship while
also dealing with some final echo
soldiers until we make it to him again
trishka discovers the truth about her
father ishii gets killed and we attempt
to kill serrano ourselves
of course nothing goes grayson's way as
apparently serrano is
alive trishka and grayson then make it
to the last escape pod before the bomb
blows off and the game
ends we don't get to kill serrano but we
do get to escape the planet
we also get a small ending cutscene that
shows that ishii is still alive thanks
to the ai and some medical attention
it would be a fairly interesting ending
if this game wasn't 10 years old
it's clear this game hasn't gotten a
sequel since then so we really don't
know what exactly happened
i'm assuming the devs did this to have a
backup plan in case things blew up and
got a ton of sales but it doesn't seem
like that's the case
after doing a small bit of research it
does seem the developers people can fly
were then assigned to gears of war
judgment under the orders of epic games
they then eventually became an
independent company in 2015 and then
said that they wanted to give the series
a second life and an attempt to make it
more popular they did make a remastered
version of the game bullet stormfall
clip and it did prove to the team that
the game is quite popular and that there
may be a chance for a sequel in the
future for now though who knows what's
going to happen
once you beat the campaign though you
can do the overkill version we discussed
before but
what else is there to do well the game
did have multiplayer but it's not as
popular as it used to be
i couldn't find a match after searching
for a while so i decided to look up some
footage myself and it seems to be a
horde mode style
game where you reach a certain amount of
points within a certain amount of
enemies
if you don't reach the point threshold
then you lose other than that you can
always do the echoes there are two
different versions of these echoes the
normal echoes and the ultimate echoes
these are challenge runs through the
areas of the campaign the normal echoes
are quite easy although you do have
limited ammo and equipment but can
refill them at drop kits this is where
that knowledge of the game comes in is
you have to be crafty with your kills or
you'll end up missing out on easy points
the ultimate echoes are a little bit
more challenging giving you one
then two then three separate challenges
to accomplish before you're finished
with the area afterwards you can
officially begin the actual challenge
since it now tracks your score for the
leaderboard so you're essentially doing
four different echoes in one echo both
the normal echoes and ultimate echoes
have about three pages worth of content
which arguably may take you just as long
as the campaign itself
and i've always found that i like these
things but only for a while
it's more just a personal thing for me
i've never fully completed the
challenges in arkham knight or
dishonored i just do a few and that's
really about it
you may feel different about it but it's
never hooked me in as much as maybe some
other players
the very very very last thing in this
game that's specific to the full clip
version of the game
is the duke nukem bundle which swaps a
grayson for duke nukem and he's actually
fully voiced
listen up robot dude get your head out
of your ass
and get your [ __ ] together capisce
let's get back to it it's a pretty cool
dlc and for five dollars you can't go
wrong especially if you're a fan of duke
nukem
buttstorm is such a distinctive game i
can't really think of any game in recent
years that did the things this game did
from its dialogue to its skill shots
it made the player want to use all the
weapons and make them try new things
it teaches the player that being
comfortable can be boring i found myself
having more fun when i was actually
trying to get new challenges done even
if it was infuriating to do
it was much better than just running
around with the three specific guns for
a majority of the game and this is
reinforced by the placement of these
guns like we talked about before
making it not feel overwhelming and
giving the player enough time to have
fun with these weapons and all the
possible skill shots with those weapons
it's a game i've played numerous times
and i'll probably be playing again in
the future because there's nothing like
it
with that however we have come to the
end of the video if you've liked the
video then be sure to give it a like
as always subscribe if you're new for
more video essay commentaries like this
one
if you're a returning subscriber i thank
you for coming back and
take care everyone have a good rest of
your day and goodbye
[Music]
you